[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 y
por supuesto en el estudio está conmigo
más romeros a la mar bienvenida buena
mañana de jueves hoy vamos a hablar del
vih y el sida y vamos a empezar con una
buena noticia mal buenos días raúl
efectivamente una buena noticia que
además llega desde mi tierra algo que me
alegra particularmente y es que una
paciente en barcelona en un hospital de
barcelona ha logrado vivir 15 años con
el virus del vih pero sin ningún síntoma
de la enfermedad sin poder contagiar y
lo que es más sorprendente sin necesidad
de ningún medicamento digamos que esto
se define como una curación funcional
porque sigue viviendo con el vih pero
funciona como si no sin necesidad de
estar pues por ejemplo con tratamientos
antirretrovirales no entonces bueno es
una muy buena noticia y es muy
sorprendente porque esta mujer además
llegó hace 15 años a la atención médica
con un cuadro grave de la enfermedad
tuvo un tratamiento de antirretrovirales
al inicio también formó parte de un
estudio con un inmunosupresor que estuvo
tomando durante unos meses y después de
esos meses pareció que su propio cuerpo
su propio sistema inmune fue él ha ido
logrando acorralar el virus del vih en
su cuerpo irlo disminuyendo hasta cargas
virales tan pequeñas que no necesita
tratamiento médico que es lo más
importante también pues que se han
logrado identificar dos células que
están en una proporción muy alta en esta
mujer que por cierto se le mantiene el
anonimato y este tipo de células son uno
las células llamadas natural killers en
inglés asesinas naturales o así sida
asesinas así que básicamente son una
parte del sistema inmune que combate
innatamente las enfermedades y luego
también unos linfocitos un tipo de
linfocitos linfocitos t que son un
glóbulo blanco también todo parte del
sistema inmune que de nuevo pues podrían
estar dibujando nuevos caminos para
encontrar posibles tratamientos o curas
digamos la entre comillas al vih
increíble marca esta mujer sin tomar
ningún tipo de retrovirales pues es pues
digamos descubrió entre comillas y tiene
una cantidad casi indetectable del vih
una muy buena noticia pero que otros
casos hay más de personas que se han
curado
el vih que han dejado tener digamos esta
infección y pueden vivir una vida sana
si son casos muy muy puntuales éste se
añadiría a tres casos anteriores de
personas que han dejado de vivir con vih
en el mundo pero también además han
pasado de formas muy distintas una al de
la primera fue en el 2000 y 2007 perdón
el paciente de berlín que a través de un
trasplante de médula ósea logró
erradicar digamos la infección de vih de
su cuerpo en 2018 una década después
paciente de londres también a través de
un trasplante en este caso de células
madre el último caso que habíamos
conocido se dio este mismo año a inicios
de 2022 en nueva york una mujer que
también a través de un trasplante de
células madre en este caso de sangre del
cordón umbilical también logró erradicar
la infección y el último que se añade es
de esta paciente de barcelona pero de
nuevo es muy distinto porque pues porque
estos primeros tres casos habían tenido
que ser sometidos a tratamientos muy
agresivos muy complejos para lograr este
objetivo además pues tratamientos que no
son extrapolables al resto al general la
población mientras que en el caso de
esta paciente de barcelona a pesar de
que sigue viviendo con el vih pues puede
funcionar como decíamos con una vida
normal y ha sido con unos tratamientos
bastante accesibles entonces pues bueno
esto nos da cierta esperanza aunque sean
casos muy puntuales de las
investigaciones que van a seguir y que
vamos a seguir anunciando vamos a ir
anunciando aquí en france 24